لان الملعب الكتاب عندك بشكل عام يعني
تسال نفسك انه انت اصبت به مبكرا جدا وانا
صغير كنت طفلا في مسقط راسي في مدينه بن
حمد جنوب الدار البيضاء وكنت عرفت ردد
باستمرار على مكتب خصوصيه اقتني الكتب
الموجهه الى الموارد الصغار
الاميرات الثلاث الاميره النائمه
قرات كل هذه السلسله وكان بعدها جاءت
سلسله اخرى سلسله المكتب الخضراء
والتدريجيا همم
اقرا كتبا اكبر مني كنت من سن السادسه
يوم لانه عندما اشتري نسخه من هذه
العناوين لكي اقرا الاخرى واعطيه 20 سم
لصاحب المكتب كل ما اردته عنوانا جديد
اعطيك الكتاب ارد الكتاب 20 سم واخذ
الكتاب الاخر واهلك كانوا يهتموا بها
الموضوع المعرفي بعدين امي بائعه الخبز
ووالدي شوايه
اللحم المشوي في الاسواق القرويه
وكل العطل الصيفيه عندما تتوقف الدراسه
اذهب معهما اشتغل مع والدي ولكن في منتصف
النهار ادهم معه الى جانب الوالده واشتغل
في بيع الخبز في هذه الاسواق القرويه
المكتبه هذه المكتبه الفكر لصاحبها احمد
العواشي في مدينه بن احمد في مسقط راسي
وبدات اتصفح هذه المجموعه من الكتب
الموجهه للجمهور الصغير لان
ال المكتبه الخضراء
يعني حروف في الصفحه كبيره جدا اقرا بسرعه
جدا
فاخذ مني الكتاب بعنف
معقول يعني
20 سم كان رجل يقف رجل هناك يرتدي جلباب
اسود وله قبعات تقليديه سوداء وله شارب
صغير خفيف ونحيف وقف قال له لا لا لا لا
ماذا فعل ماذا فعل ماذا فعلت ماذا تفعل
بسرعه قال له لكي يقرا كيف يا اخي احنا
ينبغي ان نعطيهم فلوس لكي يقراهم والله
العظيم
قالوا كم كم كم
له كل الكتاب ب20 سم اخرج محفظه نقوده
اقسم بالله العظيم محفظه نقوده وبدا يخرج
القطعه النقديه 20 سم
سم ثانيه ثالثه رابع خامسه ارجوك
يقرا وعندما يريد ان يقرا يقرا يسجل علي
انا ما يقراه انا
والله لا اعرفه
مرت سنوات تقريبا في الثانوي
تلميذ فوجدت ان ذلك الرجل الذي قام بهذا
الفعل النبيل استاذ في هذه الثانويه التي
لم اقول له شيء لكن ظل يمر امامي دائما
مثل طيف الصالح
اسمه
المهدي زغلول مثل اسم زغلول السائد في مصر
همم
مات رحمه الله عليهم لكن دائما اذكره
بامتنان كتبت عنه حلو
دائما دائما